good morning John you've done a couple
of relationship advice videos in your
time but I've never ventured into that
territory and I feel like I should
because John there are millions of young
people in America today and a perilous
state so close to the focus of their
romantic longings and yet further away
than any stranger on a street it's the
friendzone to all of the people
currently in the friend zone by the end
of this video you will know how to
escape it but to be clear you will not
be able to do it exiting the friend zone
is like exiting the Earth's gravity it
can be done and it's even fairly easy to
understand how to do it but on the other
hand in my lifetime only a handful of
extremely physically fit and well-funded
men and women have managed to do it and
they were all either freaking geniuses
or fighter pilots but first let us
discuss what the friend zone is and how
to know when you're there it's just so
nice to finally have someone I can share
everything with oh I like you too much
to go out with you I don't want to ruin
what we already have I wish I could just
find someone more like you it's really
normal and understandable for the person
in the friend zone the person who's like
positively dripping with lust pheromones
to imagine the dramatic unfairness of
the situation that if the person that
you so obviously love wants someone more
like you why don't they go for someone
exactly like but here's the unpleasant
truth in the friendzone relationship
there is no person in the right you are
both in an unhealthy relationship trust
me I've been in the friendzone John I'm
sure that you have been in the
friendzone even more than I have knowing
your romantic past you're anything like
me you started this relationship from a
point of absolute infatuation did you
figure that maybe if you do everything
you possibly can for this person you
could you could get to them to the point
where you're at so you're sensitive and
you're helpful and you counsel them on
their romantic relationships in a way
that is very much like on anesthetized
fingernail removal all in the hopes that
someday they will fall for you because
you're so nice and nearby when I did
this in my life that person didn't
respect me because I didn't give them
any reason to respect me I gave them all
of my attention I gave them everything
that they asked for and I never gave
them what they really needed
like a magnifying glass and my love was
the Sun and they were a tiny ant at the
end of that beam just being crushed
under the tremendous power of the fire
of my desire I wasn't being a nice guy
I wasn't being sensitive I wasn't even
being a good friend all I wanted to do
was get them to love me which is it as
it happens a really horrible way to get
someone to love you so here it is my
friends if you want to leave the friend
zone there are two doors if you can
manage it and you probably can't you
leave through the friend door and you
just become that person's friends
support them but you know only when they
need it and you know support your other
friends too it turns out that people who
act like actual friends like mutual
respect sort of friends they often end
up hooking up but friendzone zombie lust
mongers don't get any love ever the
second door is the exit door where you
just leave and two years down the road
that person will ask you why did we stop
hanging out we had such good times you
can tell them the true which is that you
could not handle the constant pressure
of not having your tongue in their mouth
all the time so you had to leave and go
put your tongue in someone else's mouth
for a while and maybe at that point
you're down the road they will they will
rethink their position on you because of
what a strong and clever person you've
become and they'll stick their tongue in
your mouth and it'll be awesome but
since you are a mere mortal and will
probably not be able to do either of
those things I suggest you focus on
alleviating the suffering of others like
through kiva.org where nerdfighteria now
has the second largest group of all time
please go join now so that we could be
the biggest group John I'll see you on
Tuesday